hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are in round 11
with the match Magnus Carlsen versus
Hani punishing after that crazy game
that it was Game one where Magnus just
blundered and I could that Knight
captures an e6 and was 7
we are returning in game 3 so game 2 was
the draw first nipple was pushing for a
wind and Magnus equalized then Magnus
was pushing for a win and then Magnus
actually had a win but then never again
somehow tricked him and again we ended
up for with this drawn in a game - so
this is game 3 Magnus again with the
white pieces and now let's see if he
takes this chance to equalize and get
back into the match so Magnus with the
white pieces now goes we have d4 and
nipple Knight to f6 with Bishop to f4 by
Magnus in the now c5 challenging the the
d4 pawn right away
we have d5 by Magnus and now d6 so
Knight to c3 and we have a six now so
it's a little bit of everything a little
bit of the London a little bit of the
Benoni a little bit a little bit of
everything we have a four by Magnus and
the now II five asking already may be
interesting in interested in D captors
and a six-hour pass on or do you want to
go back so Bishop to d2 by Magnus not
interested in capturing and here there
are a few games were Bishop to f5 and
the g6 were played at which are
indefinitely the moves nipple wants to
play but here we have e 4 which is a new
move he doesn't allow knight Knight to
f3 to go for some some ideas like a
knight here maybe switch the knight back
here maybe bring it to c4 and so on in
the future
so Magnus will have to figure out a
different way to develop the knight
Magnus goes h3 and now h5 by nipple
we have the ship back to f4 now you've
taken the f3 square but you've again
given up control of the f4 square so now
Bishop to f5 in now III we have Knight B
to d7 nipple continues development and
now a5 not allowing night to b6 and just
keeping an eye on those Queen side pawns
we have h4 sorry h4 by black and now
also restricting blacks whites advance
of points on the kingside in the night
GTE - so here Magnus can try some some
ideas of how to get this night that the
c4 because a c4 is where this Knight
wants to go we have night the e5 by
neppo and now night the c1 so here you
can shift it over to b3 then to be to
and then get it to c4 from where you
will also be controlling b6 but also
attacking d6 which is very important so
night F back to d7 and here we have
knife to be three magnets just continues
very maneuvering the night we have
Bishop to g6 by neppo not making room
for the f5 pawn and Knight back to d2 we
have F 5 by nipple and F 3 now just
attacking that Center he captures on f3
and now G captures on f3 so opening up
the G file for the rook which will also
be very important and the bishop to h5
now now if F or of course so you will
not be able to recapture with the pawn
due to the pin here so rook you proved
you won by Magnus and now Knight back to
f7 and Bishop to e2 so just continue in
development at some point Magnus of
course wants to push efore we have Queen
to f6 developing the Queen now also
there is maybe the possibility of
castling queenside both black and white
king are still in the center of the
board and now finally tonight the C for
this night finds its way the c4 it took
him some six moves but but he got there
and now there is constant pressure on
this d6 pawn and also you have to worry
about this nice to be six jumper at all
times
we have g6 are now preparing to develop
the dark square bishop and here bishop
the h2 by magnus which is really a very
strong move it's a sort of a tempo move
asking black what do you play here you
either you either commit to the Queen
side then white will choose his plans
appropriately or you you try something
else
and there aren't all that many active
moves here aside from castles so neppo
instead goes for night dita a5 again
brings the knight to the center and now
Knight the b6 as the knife no longer
controls the b6 square so obviously
you're not castling queenside rook to d8
and now f4
taking away the e5 square from the night
this kind of releases the control of the
e4 square but controlling ee5 is much
more important as both of the Knights
are kind of eyeing that ePHI square so
here
Magnus finds Bishop captures on h5 we
have rook a person h5 and now Knight
back to c4 so what's happening here
well Knepper contains with Bishop to g7
and now just Queen to d3 preparing the
Castle queenside and the White King will
be very safe here since this point is
really keeping an eye on these Queen
side pawns and well both of these
Knights are actually nicely defending
across since Queen side so a nipple
decides the castle artificially came to
f8 first we have Queen side castles by
Magnus and now rook to e8 so now putting
pressure on d3 pawn the Queen may join
the action very soon
rook the g2 now as the g6 pawn is weak
Magnus also has ideas of doubling up on
the G file and just going for a nice
attack here Napo just goes King to g8
and now finally we have E for we have F
captures on e4 Knight captures an e for
attacking the Queen and now Queen to e7
with a double attack on the night here
and rook to e1 just defending and there
are there are threats here since the
rook is aligned with the Queen here and
the king is well allowing this Knights
to deliver this check so if you're
careless here if you try to defend the
pawn here let's say just Knight f6 check
will win the game for white since your
queen is under attack and if you move
the Queen by captures then you lose the
rook again with check so after rook to
e1 a nipple again King h8 now this will
not come with checks so you're just
gonna blunder the rook if you do this
but now rook captures and g6 by Magnus
and ok we have Knight to f6 and here
comes Knight back to c3 so not allowing
sorry Queen to c3 not allowing the
Knights to move because now if the
knight moves then just Queen captures
here will be checkmate
so instead after Queen to c3 nipple
first goes roof to h7 adds another
defender to the bishop but now Queen to
f3 again
you have to defend the night and here
comes Knight captures and lief undie 5
it looks like you can capture on e4 but
not really because after captures
there's the rookie
in between move which will pick up the
night after the Queen moves
so instead nipple goes for Knight
captures and d5 and here
Magnus starts pushing his a passport and
it doesn't look like it's a passport but
it really is there are no points black
points next to him so f5 ended now
Knight back to f6 blocking the passport
and also offering a trade here so what's
what's the idea behind this Knight to f6
move well you still can't have captured
because the rook is still hanging anyone
so bunch of capture son b6 finally
grabbing that pawn and Queen to d8 now
just getting the queen of the way not
interested in capturing the two knights
are very useful in the in the defense of
the black king and King to be won by
Magus just improving the safety of his
King and now rook captures on e4 here
Magnus allows this but he calculates it
out properly
we have rook captures on e4 rook
captures on e4 and now Knight captures
and d6 and after all the trades
characters and captures we have worked
the a6 and now Magnus has a rook for two
pieces and he's threatening to win them
back by just rote captures on f6 so
Knepper has to defend Queen to a fate
but now Queen captures on b7 and we have
this position where it's not like in
material-wise doesn't seem all that bad
since nipple has two pieces for a rook
but he's also down two pawns and Magnus
sir it's definitely Magnus who's on the
attack so here Knight the g8 and here
just Queen back to e4 defending this
pawn but also making sure that if you go
back Knight to f6 then just captures
wins the game because after captures
there's rook e8 winning the Queen
so Queen to f7 by neppo but now rook to
e8 again now again with the threat of f6
which will just win the game because if
Bishop captures didn't just rook
captures here so we have looked to h6
not allowing this but now Magnus is very
happily trades rook captures an age six
we have Bishop captures and h6 and now
Queen to e6 are finally offering a queen
trade because even though it's a knight
and Bishop against rook your blacks
pieces are really really terrible here
so if you capture the rope will capture
and
you will just will have a well basically
you're going after the ACE exponent and
there's no way there's no way for black
to defend it
so after Quinta East six nipple ghost
King g7 at least if the Queen's are
traded he wants to improve the position
of asking but it doesn't help queen
capture screen captures in now again
look the east six just putting pressure
on the bishop attacking the a sex pawn
so push back the D to buy nipple but now
Magnus just captures it and creates a
passed pawn on f5 so Knight to e7 going
after the f5 pawn and now just c3 so not
too worried not worried about this pawn
we have C 4 by nipple not allowing to
further expand on the Queen side would
be 4 but now f6 Magnus just keeps that
pawn Knight the g6 and now rook the c6
preparing to push the past a pawn we
have nice to e5 attacking the rook and
rook to c7 check now King characters on
f6 and now a 6 here Bishop to e3 nipple
will of course have to give up the
bishop for the past pawn a7 bishop
characters in the rook captures and here
kink the g5 of course hoping to to grab
this pawn which will then give him again
some chances but Magnus of course
doesn't allow it
rook g7 check King to f4 and now King to
a2 and it was in this position unmoved
56 that Ian pony should resign the game
and the Magnus equalizes and gets back
into the match so we are going into Game
four where anything can happen as two of
them have been playing some really weird
chess so it's anyone's guess what will
happen in game 4 so whoever wins that
wins the match or the tie and they go
into Armageddon and then it's then it's
just well anyone's game I believe but
after King a two he resigns because you
cannot reach the pawn here so you don't
really have all that much to do and once
this King well either reaches the pond
you will pressure it so if the knight
moves you lose the pawn but you can just
create another pass pawn here so it
doesn't really matter and the the rook
can always just if the knight moves pick
up this pawn so black is basically
without a move
Stremme Magnus wins equalizes the match
and we'll see what happens in game 4
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would once again like to thank a
Christian Sprenger Kevin Clarke Henry's
dragons a goner and so the wall and
ergo for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it until it ends so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day